This is a download from BBC Learning English.
To find out more, visit our website.
6 Minute English from BBCLearningEnglish.com
Hello, this is 6 Minute English from BBC Learning English. I'm Neil.
And I'm Sam.
In this programme, we'll be discussing our closest neighbour in the solar system,
the planet Mars.
Often called the red planet.
Mars has been in the news a lot recently with three separate missions being sent
to explore the planet's surface in 2021.
Our fascination with the red planet has given birth to some interesting art over the years.
This includes music, such as David Bowie's 1973 hit, Life on Mars,
and countless films from 1938's Mars Attacks to the 2015 blockbuster The Martian.
But human interest in Mars goes back much earlier.
Ancient civilizations like the Maya of Central America observed the planet's colour
and recorded its movements just like modern astronomers,
scientists who study the universe and the stars, planets and suns within it.
Yet, despite this, many questions remain unanswered.
What caused the marks and scars on the planet's surface?
And the biggest question of all is their life on Mars.
But before we go on, I have another question which needs answering Sam.
The ancient Romans were also interested in Mars.
They even considered the planet to be a god.
But god of what?
Was Mars the Roman god of A, love, B, fire or sea war?
Well, Mars is the red planet, so I guess the answer is B, the Roman god of fire?
Okay Sam, we'll find out the answer at the end of the programme.
Whatever the Romans thought, civilizations throughout history have described
looking into the night sky and seeing a bright red light.
But where does Mars' characteristic colour come from?
Someone who can answer that is Dr. Michael Maya.
As lead scientist on NASA's Mars exploration programme,
he spent years observing and recording the red planet.
Listen to Dr. Maya in conversation with BBC World Service programme The Forum.
Try to hear the explanation he gives for Mars's unusual colour.
One of the distinctive things about Mars is that it's red, so you can see it and identify it.
It looks red because of rust.
Iron oxide on the surface, which is red.
And interestingly, that look can change.
And we saw that in 2018 when there was a global dust storm.
Mars, instead of looking red, looked a little orange.
And it's that, you know, that changing of colour might have made
the civilizations watching Mars maybe uneasy to see something immutable in our night sky,
changing colours.
Dr. Maya calls Mars' red colour distinctive.
Easy to recognise because it's different from everything else.
But did you hear why it's red in the first place, Sam?
Yes, it's red because of rust, a reddish chemical substance called iron oxide
that occurs when metals react with water and air.
The colour of this rust can change slightly from red to brown to orange.
And Dr. Maya thinks these changing colours may have worried ancient astronomers who believed Mars
was immutable or never changing.
Unlike ancient civilizations, modern astronomers have sent satellites to land on Mars and explore its
surface. And although no human has set foot on the red planet so far, we know a lot about conditions there.
So in the words of David Bowie, is there life on Mars?
Well, that all depends on finding water.
Water is life. And as Dr. Maya told BBC World Services The Forum, with water, anything is possible.
And from all that we have learned from astrobiology, life is amazingly adaptable.
But it still needs water. So that's why water is the key.
So finding liquid water on Mars whether or not it's now or whether or not it's in the past,
tells you that you potentially have a habitable environment, some place that could support life
and perhaps even Martian life.
Dr. Maya says that life is amazingly adaptable, able to change in order to survive in new
situations. Finding liquid water could make the red planet habitable, good enough to live on.
And with billionaire businessmen like Elon Musk, planning manned missions to space,
who knows how long it could be before we see a human on Mars.
And who knows what they'd find there? Tiny worms, little green men, or maybe a Roman god?
Ah, yes. In your question you asked what Mars was the Roman god of? And I guess B, the Roman god of
fire. Which was the wrong answer I'm afraid. In fact, the Romans considered Mars their god of war
and sacrificed wild animals to him, such as wolves, bears and strangely woodpeckers.
Okay, Neil, let's recap the vocabulary from this program on the red planet, Mars,
starting with astronomer, someone who studies the stars, planets and moons in our universe.
If something is distinctive, it's easily recognizable because it's different from everything else.
Rust or iron oxide is a red coloured chemical that occurs when metals react with water and air.
Immutable means never changing. Something which is adaptable can easily change to deal with new
circumstances. And finally, habitable means good enough to live in. That's all we have time for.
Bye for now. Goodbye.